today's episode is brought to you by
America's best unlimited network don't
miss a show with unlimited data from
t-mobile
hello screen junkies welcome to the
honest trailer commentary for alien
covenant I'm Dan merle spencer j gilbert
and then there were two
number two and ii still on vacation Joe
is out starring around today Joe's out
of the office today so it's just us yeah
talking alien covenant a movie that most
people did not like I gave it a mild
recommendation but I recommended that I
recognize there are some really stupid
people yeah that's a most people don't
like this moving that and the defenders
of it are saying it's not as bad as
people say it is no one's saying like
this is a great alien movie I would
agree with that sentiment I I didn't
think it was as bad as people said it
was however I can't fault people for
saying it's bad I can pick out parts I
enjoyed they are massively outweighed by
the time I spent sitting there like what
happened to this franchise man this is
just sad it we say in the trailer but
it's gone full Terminator like I've
abandoned all hope at this point of it
writing the ship this was the last best
hope I think like it was like okay can
Ridley Scott go back and do like a
hardcore alien movie again and the
answer was kinda but not really right
it's like 20 minutes of it it seemed
like he was giving us what we wanted or
what not what we wanted but what he
thought we wanted where it's like
alright you want like the alien back
fine here's the alien you want something
to burst out of someone like fine here
you go here's a multi gendered crew
trapped on a ship that all died off one
by one but I'm still going to talk about
the meaning of life because that's what
I care about yeah I think he wanted to
Michael Fassbender is quoting Shelley at
each other and they were like okay we'll
give you the money but you have to put
an alien in as you know Morphin he's
like this fly yeah it was just like for
a movie all about like unholy weird
hybrid beast like the movie itself was
one where it was just kind of a alien
movie stapled on to like a more
philosophical why are we here type of
thing and it just neither it didn't have
room for either wonderfully develop and
if you thought the characters in from we
were stupid Oh these I can't argue with
um dum-dum I cannot argue with the
stupidity of the characters in this
movie just are they excited the crew of
the Covenant their only qualification I
guess is they're married ooh when it
doesn't even really play into anything
no I thought that was interesting like
oh they're going to send married couples
up there and like they'll play on that
and the the inherent pitfalls in that
relationship nope notes just
occasionally someone goes my wife yeah
oh okay but yeah why were they awake
when everyone else was asleep because
they're spectacularly dumb they're
spectacularly dumb there had to have
been some other colonists in those weird
pods that were hanging very unsecure yet
some fetuses you could heat it up and
hand them in the wheel yeah the very
thing never worked dies and we didn't
make this trailer with Billy credit even
as the line is just like oh well they
don't like me because they don't think a
man of faith can make informed decisions
and then they just blow past that and
never reverence it again again it was
really Scott wanting to go so much
deeper than he yeah that was only part
of one movie but not the other it was
like the face why are we here who
created us which by the way did anyone
watch alien and then watch Prometheus
even and be like I still got to know
more about where the aliens came from I
need to know in intricate detail how
they got in the eggs where did they come
from these are the things yet it's like
people it's pre colitis it's later Boba
Fett did not get cooler knowing his
backstory in fact the opposite happened
Darth Vader did not get cooler knowing
the backstory well and the backstory is
now even more confusing now that they've
illuminated it because nothing Ridley
Scott has done has yet tightened
succinctly enough with aliens is like
yeah but why was there a guy with a big
chest burster in the ship they found an
alien alien yeah the people none of it
makes sense is making it worse Ridley
you're making ever so many like annoying
questions and just like just pointing
out things wrong I really wish that you
know Simmons I don't know if you guys
have done this video reached out I have
a giant list of just things that were
wrong with alien covenant they don't fit
in on Australia right we do things a
little differently but it was just list
after list of like that was dumb that
was dumb
that was
that was very stupid yeah we watched the
trailer continue to riff on the dumbness
of the Sun the Covenant the following
trailer is way on earth why well because
they just spoil it so if you haven't
watched the trailer for some reason yet
or the movie from Ridley Scott one of
the best directors working today and
also one of the words not the sick film
in the franchise that makes it official
there are now more bad alien movies than
good ones Wow mark Craig yeah we did
discuss there was a discussion of do we
include prometheus and do we include
alien vs. predator or aliens vs.
predator and we decided we're going with
the ones that were called alien or
aliens yeah that an alien and not alien
vs. predator
messing up the timeline oh my god that's
a whole separate thing yeah yeah even in
predator 2 isn't there an alien skull in
there there isn't like that
yeah prophy really yeah it's none of it
makes any sense so yeah no we because
the movies the Ridley Scott timeline ish
movies that have alien before then we
put bring by the way it would still be
it'd be like 2 to 6 instead of 2 to 3 if
we put the other ones in there because
there were no V there would be no more
going on the good side it wouldn't shift
the balance David all yeah yep no seesaw
would still tilt to suck I'm sure
there's a lot of debate in the comments
about why we decided to include some
movies and not others but that's why the
wind Ridley Scott wanted to wank about
the meaning of life or two hours
he gave us prometheus now he's back with
a good old-fashioned alien would never
returns to its sci-fi horror roots until
it takes a sharp left turn into the same
wank job territory as the last pollen
mine backing up a little to that like
weird black stuff from this guy here
yeah here's a question why does he kill
the engineers why did David murder that
entire planet why does he do it with
this black goo that causes a whole
genocide of a race of people but you're
still like obsessed with creating a
biological weapon it seems like he had a
pretty good one right there it's a great
one
why bother building the head
crabs as I said and I've tried I've
tried I've read tomes of material this
very thing as I understand it and this
is why Ridley Scott says that he was
obsessed with creating life and he found
the engineers unworthy of being creator
who create light oh he was like I'm
gonna wipe the slate clean and make my
own life I expect suffering that dumb
out of like a Marvel villain kind of
like a blue Marvel villain but I expect
better from you Ridley that is the
ending is realistically that would it be
the ending to every Marvel movie yeah
everybody's dead and you're not worthy I
am worthy so commence the doomsday
weapon yes that's you suck genocide part
of the deleted scene that was on YouTube
that we refer to over a hole in between
- what happened i watch that it didn't
make it much clearer it made it a little
bit clearer at least though you let's
get to see Noomi Rapace instead of just
being a plastic corpse right on the
table the grand tradition of killing off
main characters off screen that alien
has we haven't that with the revenue do
and Hicks and hex yeah whoops stupid
okay continue here a toy as the last one
my name is Osmani as is vouching I'm
aesthetic you know oh god my office but
I mean that matters compelling they the
Android oh it's a great way to honor
damage
I want a short haired girl in a tank top
fighting is eatable like the 15 gilded
by sucking it is the vacuum of space man
yeah starts and ends
yeah now that's the lien I remember
every time in a franchise full of
unforgettable characters experience a
chapter where no one stands out
except maybe Kenny Powers let's party to
see all my enemies end playback and
truck a married couple so you'll have
kind of hairy until someone said why and
how it stood before now behave yourself
with my wife live with my wife's picture
as the scheduler here
I love how they coming one by one for
that will decision right like aborting
their mission because they heard a John
Denver's all thank you John not wearing
can reach Harlem okay I will say and
this is kind of lamp shading there is a
scene where the we're not Ripley yes
it's dr. Manhattan down and lays out
very eloquently why everything they're
doing is a stupid idea right that
doesn't completely get you off the hook
however from no cuz he's still like I
don't care I don't care this this is my
chance to like prove myself as a leader
like what was that why uh sure yeah he's
like at the beginning that were setting
up like like maybe his wife is like Lady
Macbeth in him because he's like they
don't respect you like you gonna do more
to win the crew but like that as another
Fred completely dropped yeah which one
was his wife was a dinner break with
Danny McBride McBride
after they killed James Franco oh oh
we're James Franco's cameo by the way
and then in the YouTube deleted scene
and he has a scene see it he has like a
flashback video Franco on an iPad do you
think like Danny McBride just called him
for the day like somebody showed up
didn't show up and he's like I know well
Cal Franco yeah I mean I'll call Franco
yeah he'll do anything he's in London
getting his seventeenth degree lurking
on seventeen-year-olds to tell me kind
of seventeen for a loop now look
Franco's here Oh Franco all right job
for not wearing protect eyes on a
foreign planet yeah open I do respect
how when James Franco got busted for
texting a seventeen-year-old girl he
just owned up to it and like that's
embarrassed
yeah it's too props to you Franco job
Franco are you gonna do a terrible job
yeah sorry mopping up battery without
detection on a foreign planet opening
quarantine rooms with killer aliens in
them shooting at your own fuel to add
this having shower sex in a horror movie
slipping in the same blood puddle
probable boy oh this is good have you
have aloneness who clearly loves aliens
and sticking your face over an alien egg
because that same robot told you to
thankful oh no all right why would you
look in the egg now maybe these aren't
colonists maybe earth is a secret
program to deport the world's biggest
morons plans plans get out humans as you
spend most of your time in freshman
philosophy class with the androids
Walter and David Michael Fassbender Jack
and Jill said as both characters Angela
slight variations on a pretentious
literature professor who wrote
Ozymandias hi Shelley we actually we we
had a debate that a Spencer you Joe and
I had a debate of what does Michael
Fassbender's Walter voice sound yeah I
can't place him but I know he sounds
like something like the closest I could
come up with get with was justice
gordon-levitt as Edward Snowden and
that's no movie yeah very cool hello
hello American - I am I am I am NOT a
British robot he says it gets a little
bill clay even when he's calmed down not
like oh no you're one of the guys like
sharing a cigarette like they they got
off say I thought sorry I thought you
were one of those guys
joe said Buffalo Bill okay look through
the Burnie security I tell me that
little force is very hello yeah I don't
know I don't know I mean it was a look
he's probably even though the words
coming out of his mouth I couldn't care
less about there's something just really
captured anybody watching my colleague
Leonard yeah do anything he played flute
if you'll see into the flute just doing
whatever like cut his hair or
yeah I will eat also that mission too
but the Walter David reveal in the movie
was but at least surprise one tries dumb
forced not twist and it breaks its own
rules because you've seen them like heal
from damage before you do all this other
stuff and like you knew it was coming as
soon as he gave himself the exact same
haircut as the other one right like oh
he's going to replace the other one yeah
forty minutes later they expect you to
like be surprised when you replace the
other one this is a movie rule and I
learned this from data and Laura and
Star Trek The Next Generation who will
also reference when you have two
androids or even people that look
exactly like each other and you think
that one of them killed the other one
off-camera off-camera but you don't see
it yeah I promise you it's not the good
one it's the bad about it the bad one
that I've just twins if there's you know
twins and there's a good one and a bad
one and let's think a talking to that
one
yeah it's not it's the bad one always
yeah always assume it's the bad one and
go for music actors get excited when
they get that role like good and you
know yes are you kidding or do they get
look they get to be on screen with
themselves and usually no one else
every actor I recommend every actors
dream on a goatee yeah alright see in
place each other's flip who were both so
full of themselves they literally can't
keep their fingers off each other's
clues
just so long so long again why what's
the simple question this is a long ones
about creativity
I think seriously so it's weird
[Music]
and yet compelling him watching himself
like honey make you a socially
compelling franchise with flute playing
but well here we are
might as well enjoy it watch me I'll do
the fingering we had a party yes I added
that we did take ups and I just I just
wanted to try those like can we add John
snickering okay I did sing I'll do the
thing too scripted the snickering we
script now nickering yeah although I did
not script it when I was watching it in
the theater that was it's my genuine
reaction tonight line now I'll do the
thing great I'll do the same ring he
experienced a bad sci-fi script in the
hands of a visual genius as you soak up
shot after epic shot while ignoring how
all the tech looks way more advanced in
its prequel and thrill at CGI let's
finally see the Xenomorphs move around
in full daylight which just looks wrong
let's see about that mannequin what's
next CGI Ripley
Nina see when he we were young with a
$2.00 techniques so that may be feasible
No
so enjoy a film that wants you to ask
questions like who are we and why are we
here but we'll have you asking questions
like why should I care why are critical
plot scenes on YouTube and not in the
movie and wait how many more of these
are they going to make as this latest
installment gives alien the same
prestige is the Terminator franchise in
that the first two are classics and it's
all been downhill from there
for me I got dragons I see you this is
better than her energy style yen oh I
got to tell you that is lower lever
Ripley believe me she's not great almost
evaded he's found and um those are
Phoenix Franco's STD and me when I hear
six more alien movies are coming out of
UI Prometheus to healing time for me
very true Dan thank you I'll say this is
my bed size life work make you all
reference out immediately I'm gonna like
to think of watching it you didn't need
a shot from straight on but I think he
has done flute hands
Picard had he does there is not in the
inner light the inner light is a light
yeah they revisit it in in another
episode called lessons and there's like
a shot of Picard and then there's like
he has the flute in his mouth
sorry I'm gonna give it and then there a
hair like that brave overly hands in
front that are not obviously not
connected to him so it's like so you
just haven't hands behind his back yes
I'm getting to play the flute and there
are flute stunt hands in the foreground
I have to find it I've been rewatching
it for a reason you'll find out soon
I've been rewatching Star Trek The Next
Generation and that is a comically bad
sandesh Picard's it's pretty fun I woke
up with a card flute inner light and no
a lessons lesson so I actually think
that this is seen there actually it's a
surprising number Picard sweet scene
search next generation that's the one
it's one of the ones in lesson one of
them lessons what a gentleman Sir
Patrick Stewart the poop emoji Weiss
approaches oh no alien come alien
covenant we didn't have outtakes was the
only one we didn't use was the the alt
for a Walter and David which was a
anchorman reference right Oh like you
play yazz flute really yeah like that
yeah no no outtakes we use everything we
everything we shot a rope this time yeah
um yeah so look really Scott's a genius
his place is cemented his legacy he'd
made just sci-fi alone he's made some of
the all-time great films things made
stuff like Thelma and Louise
all kinds of great movies but like and
he can still make really beautiful
looking films I just wanna come but it
looked amazing yeah I want him to
partner up with someone like with some
good tighter storytelling chops maybe
then at this point because he's like
he's up there he's like in his 70s
particular second again yeah I mean
that's what we were seeing now so many
directors and actors they're getting
into their 70s and they're like I just
want to go back and do when I own at the
beginning yeah would you I get it but I
you know team up with some young like
Denny Villeneuve with the Blade Runner
2049 like I'm way more excited about
that movie than I would be
maybe if Ridley Scott was doing it
because you know it's been mixed results
I mean look it's his franchise he can
run it into the ground if he wants to
share created it I did alien and aliens
or to my favorite sci-fi movies ever
alien especially maybe one my favorite
movies of all time he can he made it he
can destroy it maybe you can make a
movie about that maybe yeah see the
making of aliens assistants the making
and killing of a human killing of alien
so that's our take on alien covenant
anything less I got nothing left
no but we'll get six more alien movies
so I'm sure you'll see us back here
eventually
I don't know putting on the box office
yeah I don't know if we will see any
more but I don't know who knows anyway
thank you for watching the honest
trailer commentary I and Dan Morrell
about today Gilbert and next week we
should be back with our full complement
to talk about the movie that we're doing
which I won't reveal here okay all right
sound like a plan
thanks for watching thanks again to
t-mobile for sponsoring today's episode
check out what makes them America's best
unlimited network at t-mobile dot-com
slash coverage
you